number four the ultimate goal of gender
ideology
goes far beyond gender
a word which has been expanded you know
into oblivion
anyway
the ultimate goal is to undermine
destroy erase
truth itself
leftism is relativism and relativism is
the belief that there is no objective
truth no shared reality no universal
facts that we all have to conform
ourselves around and submit ourselves to
the relativist claims the right to
invent his own universe for himself
right even to the point of inventing
himself
he seeks to be a self-created being
making and remaking himself as he sees
fit down to the very biological level
he believes that his ego
overrides all else
everything must bow before it language
institutions science even his own dna
this is why i found myself speaking to
pontius pilate over and over again what
is truth the gender ideologues would ask
who's truth which truth are we talking
about
i was sitting in the same room as them
but they would not agree that we were
situated in the same reality
they get their own reality they insisted
and that ultimately is what this all is
all about it's about having your own
reality